-Our first guest tonight is
a Tony- and Grammy Award-winning
actor and Broadway legend
you know from shows
such as "Gypsy" and "Evita."
She's starring in the Broadway
revival of "Company,"
which is now playing at
the Bernard B. Jacobs Theatre.
Please welcome to the show
Patti LuPone, everyone!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi!
-Patti, I am so happy
you're here!
-I'm so happy to be here.
I'm such a big fan of yours.
And can I just say that
you and "A Closer Look"
got me through the pandemic.
The computer became
my best friend.
I would find you, and you would
pinpoint the insanity of
this country with such great
humor that you leveled me.
You kept me calm.
You made me laugh, and for that,
I am indebted to you.
-Oh, my goodness, thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What more could you ask for from
the beginning of an interview?
-It's true.
-That means the world to me
because I've always been
such a huge fan of yours.
And this is so thrilling
that you are on stage
in this revival of "Company."
This is a very famous show,
a very famous role.
And do you hesitate at all
when you get offered
something like this or do you
just jump in with both feet?
-Well, I actually had given up
musicals when I did "War Paint"
a couple of years ago because I
actually started performing on
a bone-on-bone hip.
I needed a hip replacement,
and we had just opened,
so I couldn't exactly
leave the show.
And I -- Musicals are
difficult physically,
and I have two new hips
and a new shoulder.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And so I actually gave up
musicals,
and then Marianne called me --
Marianne Elliott --
who's the director of "Company,"
was the director of "War Horse,"
the director of
"Curious Incident of
the Dog in the Night-Time."
And I had put it out in the
universe that I wanted to
work with this woman
when I saw both of those shows.
I gave up musicals, she called.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "No, no, no, no, no."
And then I thought, "If I don't
work with her,
if I don't say yes,
she'll never ask me again."
So I said yes,
and I went to London
to do the production in London,
this production in London.
And then of course
I was gonna do it
in my native state, my hometown.
-And then it was supposed to
open right --
like March, I think, 20th
of 2020.
-On Steve's birthday.
-Yeah, on Stephen Sondheim's
birthday, it was gonna open.
And then, obviously,
the pandemic hit,
and then we very sadly lost
Stephen last month.
You knew him very well.
-I-I-I knew him.
[ Laughs ]
I don't think anybody --
-It's so interesting.
So you don't know
if anybody really knew him.
-Well, I think his intimates
knew him.
I think Jeff knew him very well,
and I know Mia knows him
very well.
That would be Mia Farrow.
And he has a coterie of friends.
And I have a working
relationship with him,
and I did have a social
relationship with him
because we both live in
the same county as you do.
And there would be high teas,
there would be New Year's Eve
parties, there would be dinners,
but I was never comfortable,
I have to say.
He's an intimidating presence.
He's so smart and scary,
so I never felt comfortable.
-How was he -- Obviously,
you were in a situation
where he could give you notes,
he could give you praise,
he could give you criticism.
How was he when he would present
that feedback to a performer?
-Well, in my particular case,
it would depend on the show
and it would depend on --
For instance, I have this
incredible note that sits on
my dressing room mirror
about this show.
And when we did "A Little Night
Music" at Ravinia,
he came backstage with really
succinct notes and praise.
But then when I did Fosca
at Lincoln Center Live,
I, um, was, um, uh,
destroyed by a note.
[ Laughter ]
-He gave you a note
that destroyed you?
-Totally.
I didn't understand it,
and all I heard was
monotonous mush.
And I also thought,
if there was anybody
with less experience than me,
they would have turned in
their Equity cards 'cause it was
a dressing-down
that was so shocking that -
I mean, I stopped listening
because I was sort of
freaked out.
And then we figured out
what the note was.
I asked a bunch of people
backstage what we thought
the note would have been,
and then, the next day,
he came to my dressing room
that night when it was live
at Lincoln Center, and he said,
"Night and day."
And so I knew that I had
gotten his approval
and I had accomplished the note.
And basically, he couldn't
understand me
when I was emotional.
So that's a note
that's easy to give,
as opposed to what I heard.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I've worked with people
who are like that.
You know, Lorne Michaels is
someone who is also a genius,
and his notes are very cryptic
to the point that he tells them
to you, you're destroyed,
and then you also don't
quite know what he said.
-Yeah, right, exactly.
Yes, I think they get caught up
in themselves or...
-Yeah, I think, maybe.
[ Laughter ]
I think maybe you're right.
-I don't know whether
I'm allowed to say that,
but it's true.
They have a point to make,
and they're passionate
about the point,
but they're not necessarily
diplomatic.
-Yeah.
-But I think it's true of
any of us that are
in the lower echelon.
The actors are the low man
on the theatrical totem pole,
so we get beat up all the time.
-Yeah.
-It's just the way it goes.
It's not nice, but we have to
expect it from our director,
from the musical director
if you're in a musical,
from the composer,
from the lyricist.
You're going to get notes that
are -- mm, change your life.
[ Laughter ]
-Being away from
a live audience,
what is it like having it back?
Is it everything you remembered
or is it even more valuable
having taken time away?
-How did you feel?
How did you feel?
-You know, it's great.
-It is.
-It is really great.
I also think --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I think I forgot how easy it was
to pander like that
and get applause.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh...
But I think that it was
a scary time
because we didn't know
when it would end.
-Yeah.
-That was the thing that was
freaking me out.
I went to the dark side
so many times.
I thought, "Is this my life now?
And if this is my life,
do I want this life?"
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
"Is this retirement?"
But I think, also, the audiences
that we are playing to are happy
and grateful that there is
that live interaction again.
We all missed it.
I mean, just how many Netflix
shows can we binge-watch?
-Right.
-Do you know what I mean?
Without some sort of connection?
And I find that in "Company"
now, I feel the same response
I'm sure that you do
with this audience.
-It's really lovely.
-It's really --
I could cry right now because we
need that interaction.
We need that connection with
each other.
-You did something else during
the pandemic that I want to
thank you for, because it was
interesting, right?
We didn't have audiences,
but yet we also --
I don't know if you felt this.
I felt this connection
with my audience
that I hadn't had before,
because I was doing a show alone
into an iPad,
hyperaware that most people
watch it alone into an iPad.
-Right.
-And so even though
there was nobody
and I couldn't hear anything, I
felt like they were right there
and there was an authenticity
to that.
-I was! I was!
-Yeah, and I'm so happy
to hear that.
I felt you.
But you started shooting videos
in your basement
that were the same thing.
Like, it was an authentic
version of you
that I feel like maybe people
like me,
who are a huge fan of you,
maybe we didn't know
your personality as well,
and then you shot these videos
and we got to know you
through that.
Even though we were
a million miles away.
What gave you the idea to start
shooting those?
-Rosie O'Donnell.
We -- You know, a lot of us,
I think, had became more famous
on Zoom
than I'd ever been
in my professional life.
Rosie O'Donnell did a benefit
for the Actors Fund,
and she asked me to sing.
I was going to do it a cappella,
but I had to get the note
from the piano,
and the piano is downstairs,
and the piano is right opposite
the pinball machine.
And people saw
the pinball machine
and they wanted to see the rest
of the basement.
And I said to my husband,
"Well, let's show them
the rest of the basement.
What the hell?
What have we got to lose?"
And so we started to show them
the basement.
That's what it was,
the basement tape.
-The basement was one of
the stars of the pandemic.
And for anybody who missed it,
here's a quick look at
Patti's basement.
-I already made a video,
and it won't download,
so now I'm just wildly dancing.
[ Clacking ]
That's the pinball machine!
Want to see it?
Oh, my God, here we go!
It's my ball.
-No, it's not.
-Hey, oh [bleep]
[Bleep] [bleep]
The video I just sent
was pretty great,
and I can't download it
because it's too long.
What's with Twitter?
What the [bleep] with Twitter?
Never mind. Okay.
I'm gonna show you this
and then we'll end it
because I have no time.
So, this is --
this is something --
I'm very proud of this.
This is the Second Stage
All-Star 1987.
Second Stage, second prize for
most time spent in the gutter.
Who won first? Okay.
Okay, I got to stop. Bye!
[ Laughter ]
-It's quite a basement.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Quite a basement.
-My husband has
a huge collection.
-Yeah, he's put together --
It's wonderful.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-Just a delight.
You guys, that's Patti LuPone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Company" is on Broadway now at
the Bernard B. Jacobs Theatre.
For tickets
and more information,
please visit
www.companymusical.com.